you fool LeBron's been a known as a new
wine Hawkeye is a ridiculously good one
I've had that man Chevron is a wine head
yeah our phul yeah he has some up quite
a few bottles of Opus one apparently
which is Opus one is not that's that's
the guy is way better than Opus one
look at what he wrote here last night
was mad real fresh out of Advil
Jesus grab the wheel sheesh Magican
[ __ ] up with LeBron James I brought
that wine - you're the one with the
yellow I think you did I think you did
yeah it looks very familiar
yeah that's some good-ass [ __ ] wine
shot Psalm won't push a good-ass wine
mr. super-athlete there you go that's a
real one watch it there's some real
super athletes we go listen he's an
amateur
[ __ ] what kind of steroids you take like
there's there's human beings that have
just the most unfathomable physical
advantages yeah it's ridiculous
like LeBron James would have like an
unfathomable physical advantage over
someone who would have an unfathomable
physical advantage over you yeah well I
did a thing I asked the guy who follows
this Jimmy Burke about LeBron James I
called him up and I just I left I left
him one message I go I said Jim and I
want you to be honest and don't insult
me at what age did LeBron James surpass
me as an athlete and be careful with
your [ __ ] answer because I'm a proud
man man and I'll kick your [ __ ] ass I
hung up the phone I got a very
thoughtful very thoughtful dissertation
and I just got this 12 years old and
there's no question about that 12 by
thumbies 14 642 35 best player in the
country you were not that you're not
even close to that he was 14 he was 6 4
yeah I think he's 64 look at him yeah
he's a freak 69 to 65 and I sat next to
Carlos Boozer who played with him and
they're the same size and he goes he's
just a step faster than everybody as
well and just ridiculously strong we'll
see a guy like that if he was fighting
everybody would be [ __ ] of course they
were they're lucky they are goddamn
lucky there's that much money in baskets
right he's incredible
and the people go well you know what man
some things that make great-looking a
basketball player wouldn't necessarily
make you a great fighter um listen
listen to me
save it that guy's gonna beat your
[ __ ] ass yeah this he's a winner
there yes there's just a certain level
of winners there like he'd do whatever
the [ __ ] you want everyone bo Jackson
could have done whatever I worked with
bo Jackson for a week did you yes I did
and he was and I said oh what are you
what are you waves on a white t-shirt
and I was looking at the thickness of
his fingers you know me i obsessed cuz
I'm basically a gay man so I was I was
looking at his hands like who wrapped
his hands it was just this giant me and
I said what do you weigh he goes I'm um
he said I marinara he it was so weird
he's so specific he said I'm six one and
a half 240 pounds 245 pounds and he was
the same size when he played and he
never has lifted weights in his life
ever and he didn't lift weights when he
played he would just as in his words I
just strap it on and I'd hear the other
team go imposing the game pose in the
game but you have to also understand it
bo Jackson not only did whatever you
wanted to you on the football field
faster than everybody at 2:45 and
stronger he was also a was it was he not
an MVP in baseball thoroughly so that
that's on her Deion Sanders played both
ways but there's no one like bo Jackson
free that's crazy
throwing B B's throwing [ __ ] ropes
from centerfield I mean he'd a whole
different a whole different kind of one
tackle one hip injury that's ranged all
that chest well it was his hip started
to dive some kinda krytus in this pond
or something was from getting hit there
was a very famous hit that he got
tackled you could see like the impact of
the house on his hips when he goes down
at least have room am i remember in that
yeah yeah you see the injury it's just a
ridiculous happen it still came back and
was smashing home runs with a fake hip
came back and played baseball just
couldn't really run anymore you know